Good morning. Good afternoon.
Good evening, everyone.
Welcome to the talk,
Applying Semantic
Web Standards
for Knowledge
Representation at
Elsevier. I'm Veronique Moore,
Manager of
Taxonomy Development
and the slide
deck was prepared
together with Anna Tordai,
who is Senior
Architect also at
Elsevier. The outline will be
quite short. First,
I'll walk you through a bird's
eye view what Elsevier is,
from publisher to technology
organizations, so what we used
to do and what we
are doing now,
which will lead
to the question,
why do we need linked
data standards?
And then more importantly,
what are we doing?
We'll link data at Elsevier.
I'll start at
the global level,
and then we'll
do a deeper down
presentation of how we use it
for managing vocabularies.
So Elsevier,
maybe you know us
as a publishing
company, and that
is still true.
As in two thousand eighteen,
we were still publishing four
hundred seventy
thousand articles,
throughout the whole year.
But even so, if
we're publishing
articles, we're adding, data.
We're adding value to it.
For example,
the United Nations,
sustainable development goals
classification.
So the articles
are tagged, with these
different goals,
so you can see
which articles,
which research contributes to
sustainable developments.
The, funding references,
that are also in the articles
are tagged also.
So a funding body can,
look how many articles were
published based on
a a specific grant,
and we add other values.
So publishing, yes, but,
doing data analytics
on top of it.
Elsevier is a global company
with seven thousand
nine hundred
employees all over the world.
Yeah, people in my team are
working from Australia,
for example.
And our CEO is comes
out by asset.
So eighty three percent of our
revenues right now comes from
digital products.
In a nutshell, who are we?
We are global information
analytics business,
and we help scientists,
researchers,
students, doctors,
nurses, engineers,
a wide range of customers find
actual answers to their most
critical needs.
And, one aspect in
which we helped out,
the past global
pandemic was to build,
a coronavirus research hub,
where we helped
out researchers,
get quick and
targeted access to,
every research
that we could tag
that was relevant
for coronavirus
in terms of impact,
or in terms of research.
And this was
declined in a whole
set of tools that
we provide at
Elsevier. Mendeley,
you might be aware
of for managing
your bibliographical records,
but it also provides
recommenders.
So Mendeley data had a special
COVID nineteen feature.
Scopus and ScienceDirect
are a publishing
platform, so, you could be
accessing the COVID nineteen
relevant parts of
these huge platforms.
HyAxis, for example,
is a tool that is targeting on
chemical reactions.
So if your domain is chemistry
and you were interested in
research around COVID nineteen
within chemical reactions,
you could access this spot.
So that was into the,
coronavirus researcher.
The hub now is still available
and the papers that were made
publicly accessible via this
specific hub are
still accessible
for research. So
Elsevierian numbers.
I'm not gonna go through all
these numbers, but this gives
you an idea of
the volume of data,
information, documents that
we're dealing with.
And, you can also see some of
the different products that
we're providing.
So Sharepath is for
nursing education.
It's, a recommended
system that helps,
nurses get into
their journey for,
training and getting their,
how do you call it,
certificates.
Clinical key, serves
medical doctors,
provides them
access to clinical
overviews and
actual answers to
questions they might have when
facing a patient.
So it's not only static data,
but it's a lot of dynamic and
on the spot data that,
we also deliver
through our products.
And what is the big challenge
in research? What is the big
challenge for our customers?
What do they need?
They need data.
And one of the big pain points
is around data
preparation, of course.
It's time consuming,
computationally heavy.
We have lots of data,
and data is coming in
every single day.
It's repetitive.
It's not fun.
Yeah. But it has to be done.
It's like, bunny
tight, like, yeah,
loving you is a dirty job,
but someone's got to do it.
And it is brittle,
if it's done in
an ad hoc manner.
What we need then,
is to have pipelines that get
data through
standard processes,
but that convert
it into a format
that is,
easily curable because it's
understand that it's
understood by,
the wide set of
tools at Elsevier
of our data platforms.
What we need is
standardization.
What we need is link data.
The same same problem, and,
then we can hop on to the,
great design model
that the link
data provides,
because here too,
there's, enormous number of
datasets that appear every day
that were created by
different people,
by different organizations.
They talk about different type
of datasets. They
serve different
purposes, but
they're all linked.
They're they're
referenceable.
They are standardized,
and thus,
they can be interoperable and
standard QA. So
quality assurance
tools can be applied
throughout.
And pipelines can be designed
to fit the global
unified model
instead of having,
a processing So
for that,
the architecture team
where Anatolia is,
designed the Elsevier Linked
Data Standard,
which is a place
where you can find
references to,
existing w three c,
so World War Web Consortium,
recommendations
that we're using.
It defines when we're using
the recommendations
as is and when,
some specific model has been
extended for our
needs, because yeah.
You'll see in the next slide.
First, we start
with the w three
c models.
So we're using a shackle,
and it's a huge
expressive power,
for restricting
and helping out
auto populating some
of the metadata
around the vocabularies.
In the management system,
we use PROV and PAV to define
the provenance of data,
that we have there.
So entities, it can
be the provenance
of a vocabulary,
a provenance of a paper,
a provenance of
a given concept
in a specific graph.
So we can go at all sorts of
different levels.
But because we're
using standard
vocabularies, the semantics is
defined in a standard way,
and we can also interact with
vocabularies that are external
datasets that are external,
and we know that they will be
compatible because they use
the same semantics.
Vocabularies that I mentioned
once or twice already,
are designed in Scos and more
specifically in SCOS Excel.
And the annotations,
that we produce follow the web
annotation data model.
So we're compatible
and data can
be used,
by people who use
other linked data.
We can use other linked data,
and this way we can interact
with the latest
progress in science.
Because we have lots of very
specific types of data,
Elsevier has
designed an Elsevier
data model to be
able to express
information and relationships
for these different
types of entities.
So here you see
a quick snapshot,
around reactions that would be
for tools like reaccess,
clinical trials,
treatments, diseases,
because, yeah,
Elsevier focuses
a lot on the health
side of things,
your drugs, patients.
But there's also
another side,
which is, represented
by funders,
researchers, research
institutions.
So researchers and funding
institutions are
part of the people,
we need to express
information for,
because they're interested in
outcomes of what has
been published.
So that's part of metadata we
add using standards.
And a side that's not present
in this slide is everything
related to engineering and
sustainable development,
renewable energy,
which is a big,
growing facet.
We have Vocabrio's
ecosystem to support,
these different products to
support our customers,
and we have a dozen vocabulary
management teams
across the globe.
They are not all, yeah.
It's not just one
big team that
serves everybody
across the globe,
but we have
different teams that
are spread up.
And the way to,
be able to interact and share
not only vocabularies,
sources,
but also processes is to have
a link data again and follow
the same standards.
So we follow the Elsevier
data model,
which is linked
to international
IDF standards. And that way,
we can grow our
data but benefit
from each other also.
So, we have two big
knowledge graphs.
We have thirty
vocabularies and,
of course, these vocabularies
have some overlap
and, of course,
some new products, projects,
proof of concepts,
development need,
new vocabularies to
be built quickly.
And, because we link them and
we use the same semantics and
properties across them,
then we can spin off, yeah,
some quick vocabulary
or subgraph
or branches based on what we
already have and
can share across
the globe.
The use cases
that we serve are
quite varied. It's basically
anything you can do
with the vocabulary.
So browsing, autocomplete in
Mendeley data, for example.
Recommender in
ScienceDirect, Mendeley.
Classification, I
was mentioning the,
United Nation
sustainable goals
classification. There's also
topic classification.
We do annotation and search.
And I will, talk more about
annotation in
a minute when I'll
show you an actual
tool and, yeah,
an actual product
that we produce,
which is the ScienceDirect
topic pages.
So we have time for it,
a little spotlight.
What is a topic page?
A topic page is,
some sort of like a Wikipedia
if you want but for
scientific concepts.
The idea is to
give a researcher
who doesn't know
much about one
specific notion
a definition if
we have it,
related concepts
or some sort of,
yeah, cloud of related notions
and relevant snippets from our
content so that
they could grasp
what this notion is about and
get resources to
do a deep dive
from there if
they're interested
in learning more.
So, for example,
you can access it using
a Google search.
So what is
the cosine similarity
distance in NLP gives you as
first results,
topic page or at
least did at the time of this
screenshot. Not certain it's
still the case.
From our content,
from ScienceDirect,
when you get an article,
there's some annotation
that happened,
and, the hyperlink
redirects you
to the topic page.
This is what it looks like.
So here a definition
would appear
if it would have
one for cosine
similarity. And
as you can see,
the process is still
a work in progress.
So, we do try to populate
definitions for as
many pages as we can,
and we are investigating
more resources,
yeah, and more
sources for filling
them in.
There's a set of
related terms,
and here are the snippets
I mentioned.
So if you go down the page,
you get book chapters
that you can read,
that gives you
some information
about what cosine
similarity is,
what its use,
and there is a feedback box.
So for example,
here the feedback could be,
there's no definition.
I don't need a topic page if
So that's good feedback for us
to be spotting what
are the critical
places where we
would need to,
add data or information.
In the back end,
how does it work?
Well, it works based on linked
data because we need to,
have a taxonomy,
annotating all of
science direct
publications, but also book
publication and all sorts of
other tools. We also integrate
with high access reactions.
So on some topic pages,
you can see reactions.
We integrate with
clinical key,
to have
medical recommendations
also show up in topic pages.
So there's an interaction,
for a whole range of document
type that used to be serving
different products.
So if you keep
all the documents
separate in the way
they're processed,
if you keep all the documents
targeted to one
single product,
then you cannot build
such an aggregation
. So there is data mining from
different sources that are
aggregated using
relevancy ranking
to get the, topic page
having the most,
useful information,
focusing on entry
point information,
about a given topic.
And then there are
automated scripts,
but also a thorough SME review
of the topic pages
after every release.
There's sorry.
There's a quarterly release,
of topic pages.
So, four times a year,
you get a new set
of topics that
are published.
And the topic pages are using
OmniSciences as a source
for annotation.
The OmniSciences
is a Scos Excel
vocabulary that was started in
two thousand fourteen.
Its first, use case, like,
its first goal,
was to link the different
standards that we were already
using for annotating
content at
Elsevier and, that
needed harmonization,
but also to be able to do,
cross platform m and gams.
So we created,
we created
Omniscience for that
first purpose, but we didn't
base it on
the Elsevier standards
themselves. We build
it on linked data.
So we used,
DBpedia anthologies to see how
the international community in
research was
representing the world
of research. We use
some principles
as atomization of concepts,
so that we could link out two
vocabularies that regroup some
entities in different ways.
So for example,
if Elsevier were
classifying, articles,
in agriculture and agrobiology
and food sciences
as one topic.
We were creating
three different
topics to link out to these
because other
vocabularies might
regroup fisheries
together with,
other concepts.
So we didn't want
to be relying
on one specific grouping,
but we wanted to have,
only atomic entries that we
could link out for making end
to end crosswalks.
As I said it's
using ScosXcels.
ScosXcel also for mappings.
We keep external
unique identifiers
to be able to get back
to the references
, and we use provenance and,
DCT source information to link
our vocabularies and and keep
in our vocabularies as much
metadata as possible that we
could use for either
making a subset
based on copyrights,
of course,
or, yeah, making crosswalks
between two specific
resources.
So Omniscience was
created as a bridge,
and then it expanded.
We needed one single single
vocabulary for,
the paper submission system,
which at time was revised.
And so we added to,
the top levels that
we had created
using only broad
levels of science
scientific description.
We added all the controlled
vocabularies that we
use for all the,
individual journal submission
systems that was now
gathered into one.
We went from, four thousand
concept to fifty five thousand
in two years.
And now for, building
the topic pages,
willing that to
a piece that is
built on
automatically extracted
concepts from
the back of the book
index, from glossaries,
and and other resources,
and we're up to seven hundred
thousand concepts.
We use for crosswalks,
classification,
annotation, and
recommendation.
And, well, these
are the fields
of science that I covered.
So medicine still represents
twenty percent of omniscience
because our content is still
mostly targeting, yeah,
health sciences
and life science.
But engineering and renewable
energy or energy
in general are
moving into the,
the proportion that went from
one percent to, yeah,
like seven percent
or five percent.
And I'm sure that it's still
that the strand
is still gonna,
be followed.
So the main challenge
is how to grow,
the vocabulary and keep it
accurate because
we want the topic
pages to be,
representing truthful
information,
but we want the topic pages to
be on the latest,
topics of research.
So we need to have the latest
information, and we need to be
sure that it's
put at the right
place with the right set of,
synonyms and the right set of
relationship to make sure that
the topic page
wouldn't be, yeah,
incorrect and not that useful
for our customers.
So we grow topic,
we grow OmniScience based on,
customers' communities,
so mostly by,
getting updates from,
public vocabularies that are
updated clearly or at a higher
frequency. So we
keep up to date
with what most scientists are
using as reference
vocabularies.
We, get feedback from our
customers' needs based
on search logs,
and we try to make sure that
these are covered.
We also have system
of extraction
for the, trending
and influential
topics that are
automatically extracted,
from last month's research and
curated by SMEs and placed at
the proper place
in the taxonomy.
That would be
a topic on its own
to see how can we streamline
the process of injection
of new entries.
And then product
project needs.
So, as I mentioned,
topic page that I was doing in
interacted with, Reaxys.
So for this, linking between,
two products or
projects or use cases,
we had to expand the taxonomy
in the chemistry domain.
So based on the, the global,
products that we're serving,
policy or roadmaps,
let's say,
we expand one
branch or another.
But for all of this,
what we really
want to do is to
deliver data that is
high quality data.
So how do we make sure that we
do have this?
Because we are
using linked data
standards, we can
rely on standard
ways of QA ing.
So whenever one
of the twelve,
taxonomy team
develop a specific
QA mechanism, we can apply it
to other vocabularies also,
And that saves us
a lot of time and,
and that allows us to share
information and to produce
standard standard
reports also,
not only standard
QA procedure,
QA pipelines,
but but reports
because we build
it on the same tools and on
the same models.
So the taxonomy
management system
is based on a triple
store and,
so we're using RDF, SCOSXL,
for representation.
We're using Shackle's,
expressiveness.
For example, we have,
regular expression
based way of
checking that a CAS number
attached to
a concept that is,
a chemical entity is a correct
CAS number. So if
you're doing a typo,
the system will
tell it to you,
and it's based on
standard linked
data technology.
We use SPARQL for
producing reports,
subsets, and doing release
type of global QA.
We're using, yeah,
pandas and
an extension of pandas
to doing batch
processes because
it's all tables and
RDF triple based.
We try to reuse as much as
possible because
we can do faster
life cycles now
that our taxonomies
are not dedicated to
a given product,
but dedicated to some branches
with a lot of
metadata that allow,
modularization and rebuild.
And the publication
is done also
through a triple
store where the,
different customers
can pick up
the latest release.
And, because we are publishing
as a trig, so,
all the sparkle and shackle,
QA validation
rules are part of
the data model that is sent to
the publication triple stored
together with the data
in a trig file,
then everybody
down the line has
a self sustainable,
unit of information that gives
the semantics of
the data together
with the data.
The publishing
triple store has
dereferencing and browsing UI
for manual use, but
also, of course,
a lot of APIs and a sparkle
endpoint for automatic
interaction.
So that is a glimpse of what
we're doing with
linked data at
Elsevier, and I thank you for
your attention.
I'll be in the room
for more questions.
Thank you very much.